hello everyone yes I'm Martin jiminsky
I'm working at entropy as a machine
learning engineer and I'm really excited
to show you how we heard and it is at
entropy or in other words how one can
design and it is such system uh for
transaction data so first things first
who are we so at entropy we work on
transaction intelligence we enrich
transactions that is we try to extract
some valuable data from those
transactions build some interesting
insights that we can pass further so
what does it mean to enrich a
transaction
on the right hand side you can see an
exemplary transaction on top it is given
basically just a plain text as a
description based on from this
description our goal is to extract some
information for example who the merchant
is in this case it's KFC we find out
what's the logo the website we are
sometimes able even to extract location
based on some hidden store IDs that are
present in transaction descriptions we
also
can take a wider context of transaction
of transactions history of a particular
of a particular history of transactions
and and check if the if the given
transaction is either occurring
transaction is is it a subscription or
just one of think
and additionally we are able to
categorize transactions and all of that
can be achieved can be obtained with uh
just a few lines of fairly simple python
code the only thing you have to do is
import your CSV file can be pandas
before our SDK
use literally one line of python code
and voila your transactions are enriched
they should have all these interesting
information
so let's look under the hood how the
system is structured when it comes to
the key steps so and on the top you see
that there is a transaction the first
step is uh is a named entity recognition
model which looks at the description and
tries to assign some classes to the sub
screen substrings within this
transaction to locate uh pieces which
may correspond to some real world
entities it also classifies dates
detects locations
and still it's not enough right it's
just some pieces of string so we have to
do a full entity search where we are to
find out who these entities really are
find out their their name their names
website Stacks what you've just seen on
the previous slide only after that you
can do more high level analysis such as
categorization recurrence and so on and
so on
so for this talk I will focus on the
needle piece on entity search which is
really a precondition to these higher
level tasks without it being performant
and correct anything
uh I mean anything can happen later so
we have to make sure that it is done
right and besides our clients the users
of the API are also interested in the
direct outputs of this step
so what our entities for us in the
context of transactions so they can be
some organizations such as Amazon
government institutions like IRS or they
can be concrete services that these
organizations provide like YouTube TV
Amazon music
the other kinds of entities are physical
places some more some restaurants around
the corner when someone paid for lunch
they can also be entities can also be
politicians or freelance for politicians
who get the donations for their campaign
so we have to resolve all of that
but these entities they don't live in
some space they live in the context of a
transaction that's why they have
different roles as parties of these
transactions of their Merchants are also
intermediaries such as payment
processors like PayPal all their
delivery platforms which send in between
the hungry customer and the restaurant
and yeah herding entities doing entity
search is really difficult a task but
this makes my work interesting and
challenging why is this so difficult
because there is no industry-wide
standard on transaction data there is no
protocol
change of information that would contain
all the information on the
so we have to work with the small common
language which is basically plain text
descriptions some amounts some meta
information very basic like currency or
country on top of that the language
of those description is just a language
of its own
so there are some patterns that are
inherent only to transaction data so for
example you might find a pattern PP and
you have to know that it's thanks for
stands for paper right it's basically
the only place where you see this kind
of patterns there might be an entity
that's called for the sake of argument
some great company Inc with its website
it may be present in many transactions
that that we have but the name or its
website is completely distorted right
there we there
some vowels might be lost there is a
huge a high degree of truncation
sometimes there's just an acronym for a
given name
at the other times The Entity can be
determined only indirectly through the
product that they provide
and after all this laws of information
the pattern that we are left with are
quite ambiguous so you may see CK and
you don't know what does it stand for is
it Circle K or maybe Calvin Klein and in
that addition to that
sometimes you'd like to see nice
locations with a full address but most
of the time the most interesting piece
is cut off
so uh yeah this is this diagram is an
abstract overview of how entity search
systemat entropy works I mentioned the
first step was nerve named and hit your
recognition it gives us a list of
organization candidates and the location
stream from those transactions those are
just you know simple substrings then we
would already like to run a full search
using this these substrings but we have
to stop ourselves because we don't have
all the time in the world to do that and
and all the resources right there is an
inherent cost to the searches so before
that happens we have to estimate the
budget maybe using some some tricks
metadata that that we have after that we
can finally run entity search for each
of these entity candidates it is done
independently can be run in parallel
moreover
if location is specific enough it might
be
enough of information for us to
determine who who The Entity
is right so from this single so from
this step we get for each candidate a
list of entities together with this
course the scores that we assigned to
them so finally the goal is to select
from these candidates the final solution
that uh that's uh the list of entities
with roles assigned to them right so we
have to find out who the merchant is who
the uh payment processor might be it
might happen that we are unable to do so
because maybe we might have estimated
uh the budget the resources that we need
for that
incorrectly so we have to re-estimate
that obviously on condition that we
still have time and some resources and
do the search in the loop again
so what's what's about this budget the
thing is that our system it may run
in two different moments real time but
they have different constraints and we
really have to answer some of the
questions like how much time we can
spend on each query to every search
engine how many query results from one
single engine engine we can process
right it may involve some model
executions
uh maybe we should only limit ourselves
to cast results from those search
engines
because there is not yeah because if
they they incur some cost and they take
time to to execute right and we have our
database we call it domain metadata data
domain metadata database which contains
different kinds of patterns some domain
knowledge that helps us to do so so for
example there might be a pattern for
which you know that it always resolves
to a given website so there is no need
to do a full search the other times
different kinds of patterns might be
indicative of the mentioned behind the
transaction which is the most usually
the most important party within the
transaction so we know that we have to
spend more resources on that particular
body
foreign
so let's let's focus on a single pathway
let's say we're considering just a
single organization candidate maybe we
got a location swing from there too so
we run multiple search engines
and for and concatenate all of their
results together and they form three
plus three plus of queries that we used
uh to search for a given thing resulting
entity and some metadata that we add for
each search engine which might be very
useful later for ranking because we kind
of treat all of them equally right so we
got
lots of results because I don't even
might be stand in total it might be 50
but there might be some duplicates or in
general and it is which correspond to
the same underlying entity in the world
so we have to group them together and
assign the entire group
and you score some confidence estimates
and this is also the step where we
reject entities or the entire groups
before we uh move forward so uh let's
say uh
we got those groups
in each group there are different
entities still this is not something
that you want to return we're not
returning list we have to return a
single representation of a real real
world entity so we have to look up some
maybe some additional information on
this entity and then match all of that
together to get the final name that we
want to return the final website and so
on
let's go even deeper so let's just focus
on search engines right we get again
organization location that we want to
search for and there are different
search engines they have their own
characteristic characteristics So based
on that we might construct the queries
differently because we know that one
particular search engine responds really
well to some kind of query sometimes it
might be beneficial to append the
location string during the search and so
on and so on so for each search engine
we may have multiple queries we run them
select topk results or each of them then
the results are concatenated as I just
mentioned earlier with some metadata
information on each search engine so so
let's talk about search engines what
kind of search engines we might use to
to find entities for transactions
we can break them down by different
aspects so there is always this dilemma
should we use a service that's
externally provided or we should build
our own so what are the pros and cons of
both for external Services you know
these are huge
uh systems huge distributed systems many
people work on them their usually have a
very high coverage on anything so if
there is an entity that has a website
whatever it's for sure somewhere
searchable using using these different
search engines the data is up to date
right when I set up a new company or I
usually try to get it indexed as high as
possible so it's searchable but
unfortunately the cost may be high of
running all those queries through this
search engines the latency is
unpredictable and weird and we have to
enrich transactions really really fast
and they only just give us some uh some
results sorted by some scores that we
don't have access to so we cannot make
use of them on the other hand we can
have an internal engine
that can be adjusted to our concrete
case right we may use of some domain
knowledge maybe you can also utilize the
labeled data of transactions to boost
search results for certain kind of
queries we can control the cost scale
the system uh easily right but no matter
how good our algorithm is it will not be
better than the underlying data that
this is based on so we have to pay a lot
attention to duration of of entity data
and obviously there is a cost of
Maintenance and research of such a
system
so yeah I talked about some external
engines an example of them is just the
web search engines that everyone should
be familiar with like Google or Bing
right as I mentioned the data is up to
date the results can have virtually
anything they are very fine-grained they
are not just high level organizations we
can get results on a particular service
like Amazon Prime Xbox Live and so on
another interesting
property of this kind of search engines
is that they also give us results from
aggregator websites such as Yelp
Facebook and Linkedin and if you think
about them these websites are basically
entity stops and entity so we can take
advantage of them for our own purpose
another really good property of these
engines is the deal correlated with
financial data so let's say there is a
company this company grows advertises
its products people pay for these
products then we see
transactions with these entities we
search for them and yeah they are on top
of search results right so there is this
correlation
with uh with financial data that is very
beneficial for us but there are also
problems with this uh with the search
engines the data that we look looking at
is uh is uh is very simple I just uh URL
is a title just as you can see on the
picture and and some Snippets so we have
to extract the information uh name and
some tags which might be useful for
Downstream tags on top of that these
results are extremely they can be
anything so you know because you use
this kind of search engines every day
and even if we find the right thing
quite often the snippet that should
describe this thing is very uninformed
it's completely useless to us so it
might be quite misleading
and there are also some entity search
engines available in sapis they give you
nice structured data with most of the
fields that you would be interested in
and when you search for entities you get
entities you don't get
websites suggesting baby names or funny
cat videos which might be very annoying
and difficult to handle automatically
but the problem is that you search
engine for entities and you get and
sometimes when you when you shouldn't
really right because there the first
model is not perfect
to write
you know create some suggestions that
are not correct still we get an entity
which looks really nice in structured
data so it's difficult to automatically
reject those those examples and yeah we
rely on the quality of the entity data
that these
search engines are based on and usually
the they are only focused on High level
entities not concrete products right so
the company may come up with a new
product that's only popular for a
certain amount of time then it dies and
there is another product that these
search engines they only have very high
level information
uh so I mentioned that we really have to
optimize cost and time so we use Sila
for that we cache every query to every
external API we can just buy like the
query itself and all the parameters that
we use to do the search
and we do it always so even if the query
hits a timeout and we have to move
forward we still cache the result
and we do it in the background so that
it can be used later and we don't waste
all those calls and money at the same
time and we we also use this neat trick
this clever trick for fuzzy caching so
it may happen that the thing is not in
Cache you're short on time what do we do
uh we might find the query that is very
similar to the one that we're running
right now in Cache we use elasticsearch
for that which is a basic thing but one
has to be really careful with that not
to let in a the results which are really
too far from what you're interested
and we built our own internal uh search
engine but it's really a full-blown
entity Service uh it's uh it's really an
ndd store that is uh it contains all the
entity data that we have uh and we can
manipulate this data if there is a
customer request saying that the name of
this company is not exactly right there
is something missing we can add it there
right so we can control this this
database and on top of it we have an
entity search algorithm which makes use
of the label data the domain knowledge
that we have all the databases that we
uh built over time
so the index for search is based on
elasticsearch which is a text-based
search engine and Milos which is a
vector database and nearest Neighbors
search
on top of it
so the core flow on this entity search
algorithm is is very basic as usual
there is the first step which does the
retrieval thing it has to have very high
Ripple so that the thing that we're
interested in is always within the
results it must be simple and fast then
our goal is to just prune the incorrect
results keep recall as high as possible
while increasing the Precision
so let's talk first about the index that
we built using elasticsearch we try to
utilize every possible field and that
describes a given entity because this is
how these entities end up in our
transaction data so uh for name we do
lots of
processing remove redundant suffixes
like Lo system for limited reliability
company uh we also have variations of
names without vowels and we use another
thing that's helpful with fast Imaging
that's that's funny encoding of of names
so that different patterns
get the same
encoding even though they're spelled
differently that the encoding is based
basically on on the sound that they
would make uh we we added their Market
tickers to the index because this is
what also what we see sometimes uh in
transactions we inject many different
variations of the
of the website belonging to a given
entity the part of this index is devoted
to locate to locations search and as I
mentioned we try to make heavy use of
label data that we have let's say there
is a transaction
that should be
for for which the merchant should be
toward us in this transaction we realize
that DD or D or D corresponded to
doordash which is the identity behind it
so we added to the index such that next
time
we see a similar transaction and the
door Dash pops up higher making use of
this labeled data
but unfortunately elasticsearch is not
perfect it falls short at our crazy
level of uh of fast index and if you
want to catch all those different
patterns still having high record and
precision uh you you really need to
solve lots of puzzles try to use engrams
and enable some fast Imaging and
elasticsearch and in the end the index
gets really slow and difficult to manage
so because of that
for those hard cases we turned to uh to
Milos
so how does it work
how does it work so it's the approach is
quite similar as with elasticsearch
given an entity a different fields that
it consists of we embed all those fields
getting some Vector embeddings for that
we have models based on Fast text or
trdf trained on a character level
anagrams the goal is not to have
embeddings which are semantically
similar but we're most interested in
lexical similarity just based on on
characters so
then we get a query use the same
algorithm to embed the query run an
approximate nearest neighbor search
and then we get scores which yeah are
basically cosine similarity right so it
might happen then we've seen a set of
results we get vectors belonging to the
same entity we take
to in order to calculate the final score
for this entity we take the best uh the
best match over all the fields and that
we that we got for this entity we
sometimes we add more weight to one
particular field in relation to to
another because we realize that they're
a bit more important for search all
those parameters we can tune with uh
with simple by example optimization and
mean reciprocal rank as a Target
so we run elasticsearch to retrieve some
results we called milvos and and then we
have to do the pruning for this part
we do some weighting on different sub
scores but we also utilize the features
that we built in-house for these
different entities that try to capture
the proper popularity of each entity
so we just basically combine all those
different subscripts of different ways
and select a small number and uh yeah
that's that's how it works more or less
so we used search engines and we got the
list of these different entities with
queries used for this search engines and
now the goal is to do the re-ranking
resolution and selection
and the first part of that is to assign
a score to each result
and then only we can move forward to
grouping similar entities to equivalence
classes and then rejecting uh some of
these classes later
so how does the first phase of
re-ranking work when we want to assign a
score to each resulting entity we for
that purpose we use a very simple we use
rather simple approach we use a Crest
and cross encoder model which is
Transformer based model that
you can import from sentence
Transformers Library
so it works as follow as follows you you
get a query that you use you get a
prompt which is basically something that
describes entity result the search
result
and the model has to uh
assign the score between zero one for
these players to
to determine if there is a match
or if there is right
so uh yeah let's let's move forward how
to train such a model and training is
not that interesting really more
interesting piece is is preparing the
data set for this problem so we make use
of labeled transactions but it's not
enough this data set is really small so
we have to construct a bigger data set
uh using some clever approach so we have
a huge database of entities what can we
do so having an entity we know for
example what's the website of this
entity we can take its name
obfuscate it in many different ways run
the queries uh to the search engines
that we use and and just check which
result matches the website that we
started with right this is the positive
Target for the model all other
results at up to the set of negative so
this is how you can train such a model
it proves to be really really uh really
well really good
so okay then we have to match similar
entities uh
that that correspond to the the same
underlying entity we do it in rather
nice way we do it basically by looking
at the URLs if they have the same domain
and so on because
the
because doing it in a smarter way is
actually extremely difficult right if
you search for Napoli Pizza Brooklyn you
might get one domain which is not
believe it's a brooklyn.com but then you
can get results from yield for example
and there are so many similar
restaurants that you cannot really tell
them apart but just looking at the text
Snippets
so then we assign some ranks we we did a
res entity resolution
now the goal is to take out individual
scores outside and have a score for the
entire group of entities how we can do
that so we came up with the formula
that's uh that follows the the in the
the intuitions such as try to increase
the confidence for large groups that's
something that we could call voting
strength increase confidence if other
groups have high high scores right so we
just want to avoid ambiguity and
sometimes it might happen that some of
these entities that we found we know how
we should proceed with them so using the
domain metadata database we overwrite
confidence scores then based on the
threshold that we
tuned during training we discard some
some groups
so yeah let's say we we got groups of
entities
that belong to the same equivalence
class then we still are hungry for more
information that we know what's the
website we know the names we can look up
some additional info and add it to those
lists after that we merge them together
to arrive at the final representation
so how do we do the entity enrichment I
know we like the work of enrichment so
we we again use the search engine some
of them are the same search engines that
we used earlier or we use our own
internal database to find out tax
alternative names some logos
descriptions everything that might turn
out to be very useful we also are able
to determine the location at this point
of a particular
entity based on the store ID so for
example here you have a transaction
spent gigster it loves 295 and we
already know that what loves is we know
know their website and using our
entity store where we have mappings from
store IDs to locations we can resolve
the location of the given
translate then having a list
of resulting entities
we try to merge them together to arrive
at the final representation so the name
is chosen using a model that's rather
simple model but it's fast to execute
it's based on
on some features that we constructed
but but yes this is simple and it's a
quick to execute and works really well
all the tags and the descriptions that
we acquired are concatenated because we
want as much valuable information as as
possible but other fields like logos and
so on they're chosen based on the
priority of this or some sources prove
to be more reliable we can trust them
more so that's what we do
uh choose the final representation and
the the last state stage of the
algorithm is to assign roles to the
entities that we resolve so in the the
original transaction that I used as an
example we had PayPal cool they got
resolved and now the the goal is to say
which ones an intermediary payment
processor which one is the the actual
Merchant and here we rely on on
heuristics and clever tricks and
statistics we don't have a model for
that because because we can get really
far with that at this point
and another model should incur quite
considerable cost on execution so for
for now it works really well we look at
some patterns like for example when we
see a star like here between people and
Hulu it might be very indicative
uh that the people is a payment
processor we also look up our labels
store because one of these entities
might have already been marked sometimes
as a payment processor or delivery
platform we can also make use of this
information
at this point
so this is a bird's eye view of the
system of its architecture in the center
you see the entity search algorithm has
which has two modes of execution once
really real time with strict latency
requirements the other one is patch
execution in real-time execution we make
use of Triton inference server where we
have or our
Transformer models for fast execution in
batch mode we run Onyx fight models in
process
uh this core algorithm consult search
engines there is one additional internal
search engine which is openstreak map
that we use to critify locations that we
sometimes find in transactions
and yeah as I said earlier we have Sila
database where domain metadata resides
where we have all the entities
and in the search cache
so yeah I'm short on time so I'll skip
a few slides
right so
we already described the system how it
works more or less but then the problem
is how to make it even better right so
we constructed this Loop this feedback
loop that tries to continuously improve
the quality of this system
so we have results data like the outputs
from our system and we have some some
tasks that look at those outputs try to
analyze them and construct labeling
tasks so that people can look at it and
add more labels to the system also we
have data quality Engineers that they
take reports from customers that look at
the outputs and create those tasks
manually they through this entropy
dashboard they also have a chance to
hard code some behavior for very nasty
and embarrassing Traders right so they
yeah so this this all of that forms a
loop which makes our system better over
time right we have more labels we can
thanks to them optimize search but also
extend our training data set making our
models more robust and so on and so on
so yeah that's basically
uh all uh of the most important things I
wanted to convey for this presentation
okay let's thank uh
[Applause]
still have some time for Q a any
questions
so start here and then I'll come back
yeah for the real-time model how fast is
it and is it quick enough to fit into
like a credit card decisioning system
yes I think this these models are not
too big they don't have to understand
the full semantics of real world right
they don't work with very complex
queries so they're fairly small
transformer models and so on Titans they
are really quick to execute but I don't
remember
uh yeah so my question is how do you
deal with the ambiguity for example when
you see
when you said it was doordash but it
could also mean like something else so
yeah for this purpose you can take into
consideration some external data right
first of all you might check how often
in label data one particular pattern
occurred you can also take into
consideration the market of the
transaction right so for example the
same DD May stand for a different thing
in the United States it may stand for a
different thing in Europe right so there
is extra information statistics utilized
just to follow up to that question how
do you deal with those monitors if they
change and evolve over time
again could you repeat it so uh an
entity might have a new name or an old
name may fall out of favor and thereby
changing the model
uh the name you mean like what is the
name of a given entity changes over time
something like that so that's also why
we have our own internal database of
entities where we can you know overwrite
because someone reports that there is a
problem a name change right so but also
as I said we we heavily rely on external
search engines such as web search
engines and they usually uh
have the data updated
and thank you for the talk
um so part of what you talked about
implies thinking about context and one
part of context is who the transacting
parties are and one could imagine taking
kind of network information or or kind
of graph models into perspective is that
something that you consider oh yeah of
course I mean the complexity of this
system May grow arbitrarily large right
so uh
here I presented you with a very flat
and simple case where we're looking at a
single transaction to get the enriched
version in the end but the reality is
that we can
look at the entire history of
transactions of let's say particular
underlying account and and it might be
very useful in making our resolution
even better
um I think you said you were creating uh
like additional validation data by like
obscuring words and I just wondered how
what how you arrived at those methods
and what methods they were perhaps oh
yeah here so uh
so it's actually not that complex right
because you you see so many different
kinds of obfuscations that there is I
don't believe that there would be a
model that would be able to generate all
of them because they are so easily
compressible
for this purpose we we built a utility
to test based on some configurable
probabilities samples different kinds of
obfuscations we remove some vowels
concatenate swords
distorts name in different ways but not
in such ways that it would be impossible
to really help people to really tell
anything about the yeah so so we really
had to tune this too too but still then
from this tool we get the query that we
run against the search engine so
uh so in this process we still know if
the query was hard or not right because
sessions is returned that result that
will be interested
okay we have time for one last question
hi thanks for the the great talk I'll
just be curious what the general source
of data that goes into the model is like
is it coming from Mostly bank statements
and also who your primary customer is
uh so uh for the model right so
in this case when you when we consider
the uh cross encoder as I'm showing
right now most of the data is
artificially printed based on the
entities that we have in our database
some of the data comes from labels
transactions that we that we have
in our in our database which is uh which
is very small uh
what what else
what was your second question uh who is
your primary customer uh so we exposed
the API so uh our customers might be
other banks financial institutions that
that built on top of that
Solutions
okay let's thank Marcy
[Music]